supongamos que me dan tres vectores de
posición en r2 es decir me dan un primer
vector x0 que va a ser el vector cuyas
entradas son menos 2 y menos 2 como se
ve ese vector pues vengo a mi plano y
busco el punto menos 2 menos 2 es el
vector que apunta a este punto de aquí
perdón porque se ve algo chueco pero
creo que ustedes lo pueden imaginar así
que esto es x 0
también me dan el vector x1 dan otro
vector en r 2 x 1 que va a ser el vector
con entradas menos 2
en dónde está ese vector pues tengo al
punto menos 2 2
y lo uno con el origen así que esté aquí
este azul es mi vector x1
finalmente también me dan un vector x2
que va a ser el vector con entradas
2 - 2
y ese vector está aquí el vector tiene
punto final 2 - 2 apunta al punto 2 - 2
así que esto de ahí es x2 perfecto ahora
lo que quiero hacer es definir
matemáticamente este segmento de aquí
quiero definir el segmento que une los
puntos a los que apuntan el vector x1 y
el vector x0
esos dos puntos voy a llamar a este
segmento l 0
y para representarlo matemáticamente
vamos a considerar lo siguiente estoy
parado en x0 estoy saliendo de x0 así
que me lo noto aquí es x 0 y ahora
fíjense que este vector el vector
naranja es precisamente la diferencia
entre x1 y x0 es decir es el vector x 1
- x 0
ese es el vector entonces lo que quiero
hacer es sumar múltiplos escalares de
ese vector de ahí
entonces que voy a hacer es sumar
tevez es donde t es algún número real
el vector
x 1 - menos x 0
ahora bien necesito ponerle algunas
restricciones a esto porque si no
restringe te te puede valer lo que sea y
entonces estaría describiendo toda esta
línea recta no solo este segmento a ver
si te vale 0 entonces estoy parado aquí
si te vale 0 simplemente tengo x 0 así
que si te vale 0 estoy parado aquí
voy a entonces a suponer que 0 es menor
o igual a t y si te vale 1 si te vale 1
donde estoy parado x 0 más x 1 menos x 0
x 0 y x 0 se cancelan y estaría parado
justo aquí así que también voy a pedir
que te sea menor o igual a 1
perfecto y fíjense si te valieron medio
entonces este vector estaría escalado a
la mitad y estaría parado justamente
aquí si te valiera 0.25 entonces estaría
escalado un cuarto y estaría parado aquí
a un cuarto el camino si valiera 0.75
estaría parado por acá así que
esta línea
esta línea naranja es precisamente mi
conjunto l 0 en un sentido bastante
estricto quizás debería decir que l 0 es
más bien el conjunto de vectores que
apuntan a puntos sobre este segmento
pero vamos a ver en el futuro que esas
dos cosas son en realidad la misma así
que bueno voy a repetir el ejercicio
pero ahora quiero unir el extremo de x1
con el extremo de x2
y voy a definir el e1 como ese segmento
de nuevo si hago exactamente lo mismo
que hice antes y hago exactamente lo
mismo que hice para el segmento naranja
entonces el e1 tiene la forma x1
más de veces x 2 - x 1
donde 0 es menor o igual que t que es
menor o igual a 1
esto de aquí esto es todo morado sería
el e1 y finalmente voy a definir también
a l 2 como ustedes ya se lo imaginan el
2 va a ser el segmento que une a los
extremos de x0 y x2 este segmento d así
que quien va a ser pues va a ser ahora
x2
estar parado aquí y me voy a mover hacia
acá más tv cesc x 0 - x2
donde 0 es menor o igual a t es menor o
igual que 1
esto me permite definir precisamente
este segmento de aquí que va a ser el 2
y bien ahora ahora voy a considerar la
unión de estos tres segmentos voy a
decir que s
s es igual a l0 unión l 1 unión l 2 y
qué es esto pues son precisamente los
puntos que están en alguno de estos
segmentos
eso me da
a todo el triángulo completo ya estoy
considerando todos los puntos que están
en alguno de esos segmentos así que
tengo este triángulo y lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es estudiar cómo se
comporta este conjunto ese bajo alguna
transformación lineal ok vamos a
considerar la transformación de que
aplicado un vector x en r 2 me da otro
vector en r 2 y lo que va a hacer es
simplemente el producto de la matriz 1
menos 120 con el vector x que puedo
escribir en la forma x 1
y x2 recuerden que x está en r2 así que
bien lo que quiero hacer es estudiar qué
le pasa a mi triángulo ese bajo la
transformación t
así que bien vamos a estudiar qué le
pasa a cada uno de sus lados
si le aplicó la transformación al
segmento l 0 que me da pues el segmento
n 0 está conformado por vectores de esta
forma conté entre 0 y 1 así que su
imagen si le aplicó la transformación es
simplemente determinar qué le pasa a
estos vectores así que esto es lo mismo
que el conjunto de vectores o la
transformación aplicada a los vectores
de la forma x 0 más el escalar t no se
confundan temarios con leite minúscula
por el vector x 1 - x 0
dónde fort un paréntesis donde 0 es
menor o igual a t que es menor o igual a
ahora bien recuerden recuerden que
es una transformación lineal lo vimos en
el vídeo pasado así que esto es lo mismo
aquí tengo una suma de vectores y
entonces eso es lo mismo que la
transformación aplicada x 0 más la
transformación aplicada a este vector de
aquí el vector t de escalar por x 1 - x
1 2 paréntesis y de nuevo donde 0 es
menor o igual a t que es menor o igual a
bien y de nuevo de nuevo usando que la
transformación es lineal puede escribir
esto como tv x 0
aquí tengo un escalar por un vector que
es lo mismo que te sacó el escalar por
la transformación del vector x1 menos x0
donde de nuevo 0 es menor o igual a t
menor o igual a 1 y finalmente
finalmente esto aquí es igual pues esto
este de x0 más de veces y aquí les dejo
un pequeño ejercicio de tarea como test
lineal esto te de x 1 - x 0 es lo mismo
que te dé x 1 - te dé x 0
donde de nuevo tengo la restricción cero
menor o igual a t menor o igual a 1 y
esto es algo muy interesante porque nos
dice que la imagen de un segmento que
une dos puntos o la transformación
aplicada a un segmento que une dos
puntos es sencillamente
y el segmento que une a la
transformación aplicada a los puntos
finales del segmento
muy bien así que para encontrar la
imagen o la transformación aplicada a l0
me vas a encontrar quién es la
transformación aplicada a x 0 y quién es
la transformación aplicada a x1 a ver
entonces x0 en el vector menos 2 - 2 x 1
era al menos 22 así que vamos a
encontrar cuánto vale la transformación
en estos vectores
de de x 0 es lo mismo que la
transformación de menos 2 todos
y eso por definición es la matriz uno
menos 120 multiplicada por el vector
menos 2 - 2 cuanto me da eso pues uno
por menos dos es menos 2 - 1 por menos
dos eso es positivo
menos dos y dos positivos es
luego 2 x menos 12 menos 40 x menos 2 es
cero así que menos 4 en la segunda
entrada
así que el vector
el director x0 que era este de aquí se
transforma
este vector de acá
director de aquí
esto va a ser la transformación aplicada
a x0
y qué hay de qué hay de la
transformación aplicada
x 1 que era el vector menos 2 2
pues de nuevo eso simplemente es la
matriz 1120 multiplicada por el vector
menos 2 2
y eso cuánto nos da menos dos por uno es
menos 22 por menos uno
pero menos dos por uno es menos 22 por
menos uno es menos dos así que me daría
menos 4
y dos por menos dos es menos 40 por 20
así que menos 4 también acá
y el vector el vector x1 se transforma
en este vector de aquí
m este vector de aquí
desde x1
ya por no dejarlo nos falta poco
quién es la transformación
de x2 que recuerden era 2 - 2
pues por un lado podríamos ver que es el
negativo de este y simplemente
multiplicar todo por menos
podríamos de nuevo multiplicar por la
matriz 1 1 2 0
por el vector 2 - 2
los pulmones dos menos dos por menos uno
es
dos positivos dos y dos son cuatro 4 2
por 2 4 y 0 por menos dos es cero así
que es el vector 44 que sería este de
aquí
esto de aquí es la transformación de x2
muy bien entonces tienes la
transformación aplicada a l0 quien esté
de l0 pues como no está vamos estamos
empezando en x0 estamos empezando en la
transformación aplicada x0 perdón
estamos empezando de ese punto y estamos
sumando múltiplos de este vector de aquí
del vector que es la diferencia entre
tener x1 itv x 0 pero ese vector es
sencillamente este vector de aquí
así que en realidad este conjunto es
todo este segmento
nuestro segmento l 0 original que era
este de aquí se transformó en este
segmento de acá y si hiciera lo mismo
puedo hacer lo mismo de hecho para por
ejemplo el 2 y n 1 l 1 era el segmento
que tenía x 1 con x 2 así que se va a
transformar en el segmento que une a x1
a la transformación aplicada x 1 con la
transformación aplicada a x2 para
transformar en esto de aquí
déjenme les pongo nombres esto es
l 1
y esto acá abajo
estoy aquí fuera
l 0 y tdm 2 era el segmento que unía x2
con x0 así que se va a transformar al
ser en el segmento que une a la
transformación de x0 y la transformación
de x2 así que se transforma en
eso sí está muy chico
se transforma en ese segmento de recta
eso sería de l 2 y en resumidas cuentas
lo que estamos haciendo es si lo que
quiero es encontrar la transformación
aplicada a todo el conjunto ese que era
todo el triángulo pues lo que nos da es
este triángulo inclinado de acá así que
en conjunto estos tres segmentos nos dan
la transformación aplicada al conjunto s
bien esto es una gran moraleja de este
vídeo la idea de que para encontrar a
dónde se va este segmento no tengo que
encontrar punto a punto a dónde se va el
segmento no tengo que decir ah bueno
este punto se transforma en tal otro
punto o así solo tengo que encontrar en
dónde están las imágenes en donde se
transforman los extremos del segmento
por ejemplo este punto de aquí que está
en el segmento que 1 x 0 con x2 sé que
se va a transformar algún punto de este
segmento
si no me importa realmente cuál es la
posición sino simplemente que se
transforme en que el segmento se
transforme en este segmento entonces
realmente es algo muy bueno y esto es
sobre todo útil si quieren hacer cosas
como programación de videojuegos o así y
existe una terminología para ello
podemos pensar podemos pensar que la
línea l repintó aquí con naranja vamos a
pensar que el segmento l se está
transformando en otra cosa la
transformación nos está dando su imagen
nos está diciendo cómo se ve
el segmento bajo los ojos de la
transformación de así que de hecho
decimos que
l 0 donde l 0 era el segmento que ya
habíamos discutido desde l 0 estoy aquí
eso de allí
se llama o es la imagen
la imagen de él es cero bajo la
transformación de bajo
y de hecho eso es cierto para cualquier
conjunto por ejemplo podría decir que se
considera el triángulo ese triángulo de
aquí entonces también puedo decir que
tves
es
la imagen
s
bajo
y simplemente lo que quiere decir es
aplicarle la transformación a cada
elemento de este conjunto pero bueno
esto es muy muy útil cuando haces
programación de videojuegos porque como
la perspectiva cambia digamos como que
puedes pensar en que este triángulo si
te mueves de cierto modo se vería ahora
si la imagen sería esto así que pueden
ver porque es muy útil en el próximo
vídeo lo que haremos es considerar qué
pasa cuando el conjunto ese es todo el
dominio todo r n